[Music]
hello this is the iron Lords podcast
Lords of game Annette
this is Lord Snell though here with
Louis's amazing person today maybe David
hello how are you doing and we have
Sophie here playing nano tail now I saw
this game back a couple about three four
months ago and I saw it and I played it
with my niece and I was like I got you
get in here and talk to you guys
directly so tell me why don't you go
ahead and tell us about this game in the
adventures and everything yeah another
thing is that I don't you a typing game
that's what we call it so as an
adventurer a TS game you'll get to
explore a fantasy world you get to learn
a lot about the creatures plants the
people living there there's a full
backstory but everything you do in the
game is controlled by typing world with
the keyboard so no gamepad no mouse okay
so so that's a little different for most
of you know the people that were used to
playing with because mostly you know
we're always with those controllers so
so why did you guys decide hey we're
gonna go with a typing type of you know
game for this it's a quite long story
because it's also gonna typing game so
it's this one the goal is to make an
improvement on everything every aspect
of the game from the first one and the
origin story of the first one is was
like a small game concept on prototype
we made in the studio and we didn't
think much about it but we saw more
attraction and people got interested so
extended the scope and widget of the
game of the first one I became a real
game
because we are the community that was
invested in the typing game we made the
second bonus yes so so um with the
typing of the you know the different
types of words and stuff you decide to
do did you decide that you're gonna make
it to the to like you know what type of
level like what type of like a certain
type of person's gonna be able to play
it like an adult a child or what where
did you go with that yeah so we are
targeting we want it to be a real game
so we are targeting like classic gamers
so you can play it as a child not too
young but yeah the real limits is how
good you are with typing so you don't
have to be a very fast or very good
timer the game is even supposed to
adaptive difficulty so the Miska moves
slower if you are slow typer
so what everyone has the same experience
but if you don't know any other type is
going to be going to be hard for you to
play the game yeah cuz if if you you're
watching here like at the beginning of
the game you know you can kind of take
your time to kind of get used to how
you're playing that you sure you're
going along and you're taking you know
the the character the the protagonist
and this whole entire game - don't ask
learn about her environment you'd say so
the whole gathering aspects of you know
the different types of I would say
floral around and the creatures and
things like that why did you want to add
that to her into this game as ready as I
said from the first game we had a nice
story but not very adept yet
so we wanted to add that in this game
because that's what something that I
wanted from the moment I really wanted
to push that and it's actually you're
collecting law about things is your main
rule to order in the game so that they
all want to learn about that yeah it's
actually the knowledge you get is like
experience points in other RPGs so you
get power-ups from that too
yeah so how many how many people are on
your team that are working on this right
now right now it's like five of us but
we were eight depends a bit like
sometimes we are more or less the needs
yeah but the biggest the team was was
eight yes so now what type of engineer
you guys using for this you guys using
really that's one excellent
so why don't you go and just kind of
explain you know where she's what she's
doing what she's going through cuz you
know she's got magic and she's you know
doing different types of things and so
this so this is a demo but we made
specifically for parts and events so you
get to unlock a few spells quite fast so
here you have a fire push highs so she
just used a fire on top of an enemy so
to cast a spell you have to type a few
key words so she just used fire but you
can combine them to have a fire ray
allowed to cast a large ray of fire so
fire is useful to defeat more enemies
but here she's going to use it in a more
first old-fashioned to melt the ice and
cross it right and sometimes you have
different approaches to the same problem
we may see that a bit up enough to go
there where you have to find your way
through and me so you don't defeat them
by using fire and brute forcing your way
through you can use ice to protect
yourself with ice walls on be more
sneaky yes the way you want to play yes
one of the more interesting things about
this game when when I was playing it was
your kind of what you start going you
have puzzles in it too so there are
certain situations and things you have
to kind of know and like kind of take a
second and just not try to like push
your way through it but you have to kind
of go oh okay so there's there's some
grass there but I gotta get there so I
have to use water so can you explain
were like I said we wanted to make the
game deeper from the first one yeah you
have so much you can do this typing yes
yeah too much and they are from new
worlds so the depth in gameplay had to
come from a more systemic approach to
that spread so you have a lot of
interaction between yeah
so when we add an item in the game a
feature we try to make it interactive
all with everything else cultured so
yeah if we put ice that means that the
water I was doing to be frozen that if
you but ice and enemy is going to slow
it down and such yes yes the different
type of like elements and magic why
would you let you kind of like push
through that because like the first game
also yes okay so because it made sense
your typing
yeah so we're trying to find can't
believe related to typing so that makes
sense but you have exactly
so you're casting a spell you're saying
the world right things in your book
right she has a book yes she write when
she writes pelacone she writes it down
so you have to write yourself the key
world as if you were writing into your
phone right so that it makes sense yes
now I full disclosure I didn't play the
first one but that's what that's why I'm
learning new information
so the that you have a fox on us correct
so you get no spoilers here you get in a
very unique way I don't want to say how
so what did you want to you know add
that just to increase travel speed
through the map yeah so yes it's because
of that but it's a fox
yeah because of something in the first
guys yes
so it's the two games are not related in
the story and the universe but we like
to call it a spiritual successor yeah
and the Fox was a very important part of
the first game okay which was for the
same reason so we should all get the
first one so you can get the second one
happy story so yeah the the Fox was here
for the same reason we are the orange
box in the first game and we made the
blue fox in the new one okay so keep
that that's like so um so how how was
how are you enjoy are you enjoying this
how is it the Taiping going for you is
that you know the speed too quick cuz
it's slow how do you feel about it
played very quickly because I know the
game by hurried but he rhymes it is a
dated to go into the final battle
because I don't know that's probably
fine now yeah go ahead do it you got a
dim so when you're going through like
the the the story and when you decided
that we want to have like large battle
sequences and stuff like that how did
you kind of decide hey we're gonna do
like this type of a boss or that type of
boss guys just collectively just sat
down talked about it yeah yeah it has to
be it's a way to balance the rhythm game
and you have different things to do with
the same tools sometime it's a battle so
it's more stressful yeah because it
really works well because you have a lot
of work to type very fast you think
you're not going to do it yeah
instinctively you know all the letters
are actually you're better than you
think you are socks well so you know we
we kind of collectively put on what will
be the theme of one biome the people
will live there what is their purpose
when do they like or not and we try to
make everything even the law of the
branch
to be tied together so we need a lot of
brainstorm - a lot of ideas but spitting
the same limb each biome okay this is a
forest in the game you're going to be a
to different biomes okay so how many how
many levels are there right you know
that you guys have right now or going to
make or it's gonna be three biomes okay
for about eight hour of gameplay
if you don't explode riffing success
Louisville it can become a bit more
open-ended as you explore so how long do
you think it would be for you to play if
you know leisurely playing through this
if you kind of rush to the end if you
Navi about eight hours as the first one
was but you come back track and explore
side areas did you ever ever think about
you know changing it to make it like
easier almost like to like teach how to
like you know like children how to be
end up loser using that because this
generation that's coming up is so video
game oriented like you know I feel like
you can kind of make your juice it's
almost like those are two and schools
and things like that because you know
kids gonna want to sit there and learn
how to type but they want to play a game
they're gonna learn how to type how do
you feel about that the answer is kind
of yes um no yes the tqg supposed to add
up to your typing speed so if you type
it slowly
you want to learn to train yourself at
typing you can use the game to train and
type faster but no you don't really
learn typing by playing the game because
we don't teach anything we don't do the
tutorial specifically we are teaching
the right hand positions the brats the
first one has been used in some schools
because it's on a platform called
teacher gaming that can be you as soon
as you schools mostly for training to
type vocabulary because you take a lot
of words so you can learn vocabulary
from different languages right so it
could be used for that but we don't have
plans to go further on teach really the
typing really it's really good
so you're going through your you know
almost you know it's got it because I I
loved I loved it when when we were
playing there there was specific things
that like I thought they liked the
graphics for it was really really nicely
done I liked how you know you're the
character you meet they you know she has
to have her book to have our spells and
stuff like that so you can use you know
use your fire use your your ice you use
your you know your water abilities which
I thought was very interesting and I I
really I really like this game a lot so
I would like to say thank you very much
I you know you guys want to go check
this out it is on Steam I heard well
it's gonna be right now it's onion
steaming because it's on an early access
yes and it's going to be a thing so be
on Steam and so what so when it's an
early access when do you guys have
expected to be full release done by the
end of the year when do the your needs
done when I say what when you feel that
it is a hundred percent completed I like
that so I like it when games when we get
them that you know that you feel them
and you're like okay these are good this
is our 100% completed and you know you
know you're happy with it the developer
is happy with it and and I you know I
love it so it's great so okay so yes
well thank you very much aggurlie
appreciate perfect timing finished it
out perfect look at that great job thank
you thank you very much this is Lourdes
narro here
thank you very much and thank you very
much
proof thank you very much you helped
you